こんにちは
私はスティック雨と申します
こちら youtube でーんん言葉の勉強についていろんなビデオだしています
自分も非常に言葉の勉強大好きなんですよ
まず息子と一緒にですねリンクという言葉の勉強のウェブサイトも作りましたし
そして最近12年ですね60歳になってから
9ちょくらいの言葉を勉強したわけですよ
全部流暢に話せるわけじゃないんだけども
まあ免許言葉を勉強するの好きなんですよね
もう全部で171718ぐらいの言葉を電気あのを話せること
んですよねえっ
それでこちらのあの家のちゃあなんでですね
こういう質問がありました
あるいはそのお願いあったわけですよね日本での英語教育について話ししてくださいと
いうことでした
もちろんまた機は細かい事は知りません日本の架空さの英語学校でどういうふうにその
英語を知っているのか私は知りませんけれども
は滝僕の受ける印象はですね
2つのポイントがあるんですよ日本の英語英語勉強英語教育ですね
一つはと行く統一に対する関心
でもう1つはその英語会話という一つのその勉強
徒歩度というか
何ですね私はん
あまり位
理想的じゃないと
まず遠い件について申し上げますとですね
日本の教育その
toeic テストを受ける人たちの結果が
実績があるですね世界
それぞれの国々と比較するとですね
非常に低いんですよ水準が皆
まあ台湾とか韓国と並んで低いんですよね
その理由はもちろん
一つはもうヨーロッパの国はねええ
5以外の国その言葉の人たちがエコのヨーロッパの言葉であるからその覚えやすいと
そういう点は確かにありますよ
でもう一つはですね日本で toeic を受ける人たちの数が非常に多いですよだ
からあんまり大したその
英語数じゃなくてもえっ toeic を受けると
で何回も受けるというなんか方法があるんですよねだから非常にその
遠い国対する
集中場が高いんですよそれは間違ってると思うんですよ
それが一つでもう一つはその英語会話っていうのはね
もう後6人10人の日本人同1
その英語が僕号であるその英国 ge の銘菓人と
交えてね無地柄て強いいろいろ会話すると
自ずから水曜が水曜が良くなるとそれも間違う
間違い
私が推薦したいのが遠い区はですねー
かなり高い合意
語彙力がないと
もう受けない方がいいですよ
意味がないんです
まずそしてこのほかの日本人の学生たち同士で
グループで+でですねお互いに英語で話しするようなこともやめなさいと
それよりもたくさん
英語聞いたり
読んだりしてください
もう毎日
磯野1時間の映画英語は会話よりも一時元
聞いたり読んでる読んだりしてください
吐息の結果はですねと意気というテストは基本的には合意の数字のテスなんですよ
それもいろんなあの研究結果も異常に明らかにしています
語彙レベルがですね高い人たちがその実績等駅での実績は高いんですよ
その関連性がそのリスティングですねあの
聞く方の提出の場合はもっと低いんですよね
その理由は
[音楽]
大部分の人がねぇまあ十分ですねー
聞いてないんですよ僕は言葉を勉強するときに3対1
聞く描画
時間
3倍多いんですよ読むよりも
なぜかというとヨンダル読んだり時にですね読むときにですね理解できやすいわけです
よ
知らない単語も調べたりしてただそのて素敵ステがないと聞くだけでですねもっと難し
それが
慣れるまでにしないといけませんでもちろんうち論リンクというウェブサイトもこの
読むとき服とですね
訓練するひとつの正
場所でありますけれどもで僕も自分でいい今アラームを勉強したりした駅してですね
グリー者頃仕上げは韓国を勉強ししている時にですね
まず pict 読む
テストはもうあとでもいい
s というのはその言葉というのは習うんじゃなくてなれる
なれるずローが角があの色たかもですね
整理するんですよ自然的に
町化しそれのためにですね十分な経験をそのずローに与えないといけない
だからたくさんがそして英語介護もそうなんですよ
そんな自分がうまく理解できない日
その単語でお鯉がをあまり持てないときにですね
そして2分丈路日本人同比で悪い
その初品でそれを話ししても意味ないんですよ
もちろん日本のその
何ですか構造ですねごとく言葉の順序単語の状況その他ヨーロッパの
思いまー英語なんかに比べて間違うんですよだけでも
私も英語出身で日本語もべ勉強できたわけですから日本人も日本ムーグ出身でご
benq するが
することもできますそれはなれなれる
慣れるまでにたくさんたくさん
その
ジュノーにその刺激をあの与えないといけません
だからん
流暢に話せるためにまずそんなにあの
豪遊動いの水準が低い特にソンネン話しなくてもいいからまずその辺の数順
もうレベルアップしないといけませんレベルアップしたときに
もう
非常な幅広いその会話できるときにじゃあたくさん話ししてください
そしてかなりのもう
合意主人がある時にもうたくさん聴いたり理解力が高いときにそれじゃあどうぞ
当駅のテストあのやってくださいと
それが私が推薦するところなんですよここ日本に着いた時に日本日本語の学校最初の
ひと月だけ
日本語の学行ったんですよその学校でですねええ
その先生がねまだ覚えてますよそれもだいぶ前ですけども
ニット堀先生という方がそこで心と心と
みんなもうアメリカ人やフランス人がみんなお互いにこう日本語で話そうとしたわけ
ですよ
あるいはもう意味ないですし僕そう思った1月
もう
終わってからも僕はもうやめましたあんなほどばもうしません
自分でもう日本語の
ジャイ呂
団例えば号異形のついている材料
まあそれはだいぶ前ですけども
5インターネットなぁ存在しなかった時でしたけれども
たぁくさん聞いたりたくさん読んだりそしてある程度自信がついたらそれじゃあ
周りの日本人色といろんなテーマについていろんな馬名見ろまあそのシチュエーション
ですねええ
関連で日本語を話しをしたわけですよ
たくさんたくさんも失敗もしましたエラーもしました
石傾い少しずつ少しずつ
まあ僕の日本黒水温がまあ改善
改善したわけですよだから
けっ結論として
まずたくさん聞いたら
たくさん読んだりー
号用 web love してそれからとい
それから a の海はいい
というのが僕の
あの意見ですで多分
日本の英語教育はですね処理
そうじゃなくてその等いくの民の
合意を勉強したりそして
クラスで
他の日本人の生徒たちと会話したりして
あまり良くないを聞いたりしてそして結論としては
うーん
日本の馬やば英語のままじゃ
例外もたくさんありますけれども一般的に水温はそう高くはないです
じゃどうマヤとそれなら
[音楽]
ん